large crowds of protesters blocked
streets in East Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
yesterday calling for change after an
officer shot and killed an unarmed
17-year old cell phone video appears to
show Antoine Roe's junior running from
police on Tuesday night three gunshots
can be heard police say the video might
not tell the whole story Susan Koeppen
of our Pittsburgh station KDKA is at
East Pittsburgh Police Headquarters
Susan good morning good morning this
area was filled with demonstrators
yesterday the police officer involved in
the shooting has not been identified but
we do know that he was new to the force
and had just been sworn in people in
this community are outraged and looking
for answers protesters filled the
streets at one point blocking a law
enforcement vehicle they're demanding
answers in Tuesday night's fatal police
shooting of Antoine Rose jr. captured on
cell phone video why are they shooting a
home rose is seen in a light-colored
t-shirt and appears to be running away
from police rose was shot three times
and died at a local hospital still
doesn't even feel real good Allegheny
County police superintendent Coleman
McDonough yeah I understand in today's
atmosphere any time a young man is
killed there's there's cause for outrage
in some areas McDonough says the officer
involved has been placed on
administrative leave as they conduct an
independent investigation I would urge
people to give us time to conduct an
objective investigation to gather facts
McDonough says the vehicle Rose was in
matched a car involved in a nearby
drive-by shooting when person in the car
was detained and later released and
police say they found two firearms in
the vehicle but Rose was unarmed as he
and another suspect ran away and the
officer opened fire Rose's uncle says he
sees rage growing in his community amid
reports the officer had just joined the
force police officers I know they got a
very hard job and everything
but you know what you know you got to be
fit for the job superintendent McDonough
says the police officers involved did
not have body cameras and there were no
cameras in the police cars to capture
this incident there is another protest
planned for later today and that third
suspect who fled from police is still on
the loose
Gail Thank You Susan it's another
upsetting story I know they said you
know the video doesn't tell the whole
story but what we're seeing on the video
was very disturbing so I hope they tell
the rest of it soon and I think it's
important to point out the officer
charged with the shooting he was new on
that force but he had worked he was a
veteran officer he'd worked at other
departments for eight years so I think
it's important to point that out yeah it
was not a rookie on the job very
upsetting story